one of the biggest films this summer is
the new plan of the Apes movie war for
the planet a game like that moving out
and people are saying the apes in it
looks so realistic you immediately
forget that they're all
computer-generated well guess what this
is kind of cool I hired the people
responsible for that technology and as a
special treat you were about to
experience some of that incredible CGI
magic right here in this theater is this
cool away ladies and gentlemen of Comic
Con get ready to be invaded by the
planet of the a
[Applause]
no no wait a minute wait a minute
stop stop No no one bow down what's
going on here I thought we were gonna
see realistic CGI Apes not a bunch of
out of shape actors in green pajamas
what's going on these new pajamas
these state of art motion capture suits
whoo 20 grand each whoo money use
imagination oh I can use my imagination
I paid a lot of money for this and it
looks incredibly lame I mean look at
that guy look at that guy
and you yeah what the hell is your name
my name's sake
[Applause]
forget that [ __ ] what's your real name
Randy Schwab honor to meet you big fan
big fan okay Randy what's what's
happening here okay I'm a silverback
gorilla about seven feet tall big scar
right down my face and this is my ape
army
hey man how's it going mr. Newton and
those guys are riding a CGI horse okay I
thought that was a giraffe no it's a
horse it's gonna be badass you just need
a little more time okay how much stuff
how much time do you need like five six
months man no no six months that's
ridiculous
thanks for giving it a shot but one of
you guys just go home okay but we had
this really big ender where we put you
in a massive cage you put me in a big
cage yeah you'll love it okay guys a pop
[Applause]
oh no this is this is really stupid I'm
sorry
use your imagination this is I'm not
gonna do that
you